and stuff being moved around and Halo
might not have the these people leading
it for it they came out they told you
they're leading it for it this is going
to happen it's just they turned it into
a fanboy War I mean what I didn't like
about it I mean this is
Halo though yeah this is the best and In
fairness if I gotta play Devil's
Advocate In fairness this is the same
company that has an intent to acquire
Activision Blizzard kick so the talk is
if they can't manage their own Flagship
title how can they hope to manage all
these other Studios they look to acquire
that I don't feel is fake outrage I
filled out this is a valid question that
people can present and say you got to
get your own house in order before you
think about doing other things okay we
all know and I've always said it was
only one Studio that was putting in the
bad reports I agree right but it